good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday this is a
very happy monday for me because after
weeks of waiting my new computer is
finally here and i'm a brand new woman
if you're watching on youtube hi
everyone you can see me in 1080p without
having to use a webcam which the webcam
was the thing that was not syncing my
lips to my audio and now i think today
we have it under control hi claudia how
are you doing i just don't think you
could have picked a worst day to look so
beautiful and premium because if you
look at me i look exactly how i feel
which is just exhausted and ugly and
gross so i'm so happy for you but also
slightly offended
you look beautiful you had such a
jam-packed weekend so it's okay if you
know
you're not feeling your best can you
tell us about your historic weekend at
parks casino
i mean i was also in dc like don't
forget i've literally been around the
tri-state well no not tri-state new
england
no
northeast
sure
so yes on thursday we headed to dc
we had the most amazing show like i am
very very hard on myself
and
when i got off stage in dc i felt like
the roof almost blew off the place like
i had the best
[ __ ] time literally and then we went
out to dinner at le diplomat which i had
never been to which is really the most
delicious restaurant of all time
um and it was just like an amazing
weekend i love dc i never really have
been there before like i've been for
tour but i've never really spent time
there and it was really kind of
everything of the sort
and then we drove to parks casino would
you say i love dc
i actually would like it's an extremely
gorgeous town it maybe it's because it's
the capital and they have like different
you know like infrastructure but it's an
extremely clean city like i didn't see
one piece of trash on the ground wow
that's new that's cool
yeah it was shocking it was just
beautiful like i really enjoyed it and
we had the best show and it was the best
literally i think the best audience i've
ever had in my life like they were
perfect like i just loved i thought it
couldn't get any better than dc like i
really thought that the d scenes
the d scenes yeah
okay but then
the show of like the next morning
well i don't really want to spoil it
because we did vlog for the patreon it's
currently exporting from my computer it
will be up today on patreon.com morning
show so i don't want to spoil but there
was like a lot of drama in the parks
casino
show first of all we
we had like some weather that was very
allegedly you know destructive but then
like it wasn't there was a lot going on
it was whitney heather bad weather
whitney heather
bad weather
um we talked about in the vlog so i
won't spoil it but it was amazing so i
had a bunch of friends come up for the
show we had the best time like the show
was amazing then we you know we hung out
at the casino for a bit we went back to
brian's house this is my first time
being at brian's house and that's where
i currently still am
um so it was i just don't i don't want
to spoil it because the vlog is really
good and i think everyone's gonna love
it but it was um
it was an amazing amazing weekend
personally professionally
very grateful to everyone who came out
to shows and i hate you know that the
weather got uh
ruined a lot of people's chances of
coming because they didn't want to you
know drive for four or five hours just
in case there was like this crazy
nor'easter so i totally understand that
part definitely sucked
but i don't know maybe i just have to
come back to philly
i think that you do it looks so fun i'm
so glad that you guys vlogged because i
got to you know feel like i was there in
spirit and i feel like i got the gist of
the evening and so another great vlog at
patreon.com there's a lot of snatcher
there haven't seen her in a while so
always good to see what's up with the
snatcher and there were some really cute
sweet moments that had me laughing out
loud honestly
really like which one like when
when ben got that good news and you guys
were being cute and then he dropped his
phone
yeah i was just laughing that was a good
one i thought you were gonna say when
brian was like give me a spritz oh my
god yes yes that too
that too oh that was also just like why
it was such a great weekend so spritz
was the not spritz parks casino was the
first show we were able to successfully
sell spritz into and not only did we get
it sold into the casino the toasters
sold it out before the show even started
so we were all like quaking and there's
been a lot of questions about what shows
spritz will be at moving forward now
i'm just a messenger and i can't
remember the list that ben told me but i
want to say he said fort lauderdale and
dallas as well and a couple others oh
that's so exciting
it seems as though the weekend was
fueled by spritz like powered by spritz
everyone's energy excitement
you know good vibes we're just courtesy
of spritz society so
check out spritz if you haven't already
how are you i haven't even spoken to you
i know well you've been so busy i'm good
you know i would say same as the last
time that you saw me
nothing quite new to report just been
relaxing even though it was a long
weekend for me and that's usually when i
start to go a little stir crazy up in
here it went by pretty quickly and i
felt like my um
my mental health was in check so obvious
i didn't
require that many hobbies i was watching
a lot of poldark which i need to take a
break because it's a really good show
but do you find i feel like with every
tv show these days it's like the people
that you're supposed to be rooting for
are constantly losing being losers no
like [ __ ] up and like the villains
are like they're they're winning so i'm
like this will be a more enjoyable show
if i'm rooting for the villains so now
all of a sudden like yeah you know like
because they're i can only take so much
loseriness from the people that i love
of course so i just it's more enjoyable
to switch sides and root for the bad guy
these days because they are always
winning like poldark i just
i can't
so i have one more season that must be
so hard for you it is it's like
frustrating it's like why am i watching
these losers lose he's supposed to be
like the greatest
guy and he can't even like come toe to
toe with george warlock like what's
what's the t
but i have one more season left i'm
taking a little bit of a break because
i'm reading the book for the redheads
new episode drops on thursday gotta get
the girls back together
and the book is really good it's so
different from what we've read in the
past it really feels like a
book that could be a tv show or a movie
that's like a thriller it's very fast
paced and there's a lot of twists and
turns so if you want to become a redhead
it is never too late claudia
i can confirm that it is never too late
but what about for you
to become a redhead or to host the
podcast to become a redhead
um the thing is is like i'm on such a
sporadic reading journey like i read six
books in december and not one in january
do you know what i mean like it just
really doesn't fit my reading schedule
that's the only thing
okay well
fine did you see that there's a new
colleen hoover book out
i did are you gonna read it i haven't
read it yet yeah at some point yeah when
i feel like it's time to pick up my
kindle again yeah i haven't read it yet
either snitch needs to read it and let
us all know if it's worth if it's
worthwhile
right now the book i started in december
that i still haven't finished is the
hating game that they turned into a
movie with lucy hale and to be
completely honest it absolutely sucks
yeah i have no interest especially
because i'd rather see the movie and
i've learned that i don't like
reading the book and seeing the movie
it's one or the other and i love lucy
hill so i want to watch a movie
well speaking of books being turned into
movies yesterday when everyone was here
taylor strecker taylor donahue margot
was here brian obviously because we're
at his house my friend erica i made them
all watch something borrowed and we vlog
it because it's an important piece of
cultural
history and i thought it was important
that everyone see it and then i got them
all like on the something blue train
brian has been in contact with emily
giffin they've been dming um so we're
we're working on this project full steam
ahead
on getting the sequel made
yeah
yeah now that's a great way to use your
influence and your platform for good get
that sequel made agreed
okay that's exciting that's exciting i
won't get my hopes up but if you can
pull that off i'll have them don't
do not pull do not get your hopes up
it's definitely not happening sorry i
yeah no i just want to set like kind of
level expectations in no way shape or
form is is the sequel happening in mind
i think tpg should get into the movie
business
talk to him about it i think so too
should we like crowd fund what's it
called like yeah can you raise money yep
we should crowdfund like 50 million
dollars or however much you need to put
together a movie i just think like a
little too much time has passed in my
opinion in order for it to accurately
because the the sequel i won't spoil it
but happens literally the day after
something borrowed ends
yeah 10 years 10 years yeah yeah i feel
that way also about confessions of a
shopaholic i would love to get it
crowdfunded to finish out that series
but
you know because i like it i didn't know
that there was even
yes you didn't know that there was even
any sort of campaign for a film
well there always is a campaign for a
film when you're talking to me because
everything i love
everything that is very true
everything okay well we have so much to
discuss today so i think we should jump
right in we have got the fast five we
have to talk about real housewives of
salt lake city and um we have to talk
about the 49ers yeah which we're gonna
launch right into you want to get into
it are you ready
i am ready and i have an apology to make
so let's go [ __ ] okay without further
ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
all birds even though it'll be wet and
chilly in most parts of the country
running is still a part of people's
lives trying to achieve your personal
best the wool dasher missile the weather
repellent performance running shoe from
all birds is the first shoe of its kind
it's sustainably made from natural
materials with a low environmental
impact on the planet when you have goals
to meet and miles to log keep your feet
warm and dry with the weather repellent
wool dash or missile from all birds
don't let winter storms put a damper on
your run grab a pair of the weather
repellent wool dasher missiles from all
birds so alberts are like the coolest
thing out right now like everyone is
beyond obsessed they're super super
comfortable shoes whether you're running
or you're just like a gal who needs
shoes you know there's there's something
for everyone at all birds but especially
if you're a runner in wet conditions
these um
style are really really comfortable
really sustainably made and they're just
perfect for all types of weather they
also um
they have the carbon footprint of the
shoe printed right on it so you know the
impact on the planet and then they
offset that footprint to zero to make it
a carbon neutral product this winter
keep your feet cozy and dry with the all
birds wool dash or missiles discover
your perfect pair at allbirds.com today
that's a a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com you won't regret buying a pair
of all birds they're extremely cool and
trendy and very good for the environment
today's episode is also brought to you
by a product that really did um like
sponsor the last six days of my life
liquid iv
the new year is here and there is no
better way to kick off 2022 than by
making sure you're feeling like your
best self and honestly liquid iv is a
great place to start so one stick of
liquid iv in 16 ounces of water will
hydrate you faster and more efficiently
than water alone it contains tons of
vitamins like b3 b5 b6 b12 vitamin c and
has three times the electrolytes of a
traditional sports drink
it's also made with premium ingredients
it's non-gmo
and it's free from gluten dairy and soy
so it's just super easy if you have a
hard time staying on top of your water
drinking like myself
it makes it first of all really
delicious they have so many flavors and
they're all really really good and it
just helps with your overall wellness
how you feel if you have been drinking
it can be known to be extremely useful
in the mornings and you'll just never
regret having a a stock of liquid iv in
your home because you're always going to
need it
you can grab it um
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use the kotos to check out it's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code toast at liquid ib.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code toast
thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
our first story is some sports news and
we are eating crow we were wrong on all
counts
last night
the chiefs lost to the bengals that
animal that we never talk about and the
rams beat the 49ers which means we will
be having a rams bengals super bowl
which is the exact opposite of what we
predicted
okay i want to say a few things
since
our foray into sports i have learned
quite a bit about the bengals and them
beating the chiefs i just want to say
i'm extremely here for
joe burrow is an extremely handsome man
who deserves our love and our respect
and joe burrow
you have my support because you are very
handsome and you are very good at what
you do
so for that game i wasn't that
disappointed like i don't really care
that our prediction was you know off
because i'm happy i love an underdog and
i do believe that's what the bengals
were yes it was a big upset like kansas
city could have won the whole super bowl
and now they're not even written
yeah
love it love when an underdog wins
but we need to talk about the 49ers
because i do feel
as though like
they didn't win because i was supporting
them like i just have like toxic sports
energy and you never want me to throw my
weight
behind a team because it will destroy
the team from the inside out and that's
pretty much a guarantee you're the
jessica simpson of the 49ers
100 percent kyle use check is my tony
romo and i am a curse to the entire
franchise i apologize to every person
who lives in san francisco because your
team did lose because i chose to support
them like i know that for a fact i don't
know because you've been right sometimes
so of course it feels that way and it's
like if we never got ourselves involved
would things be different and you know
what like they really might have been
but i don't think you can be too hard on
yourself i guess
pains me to say like it just wasn't the
49ers time once again i know
no i know and
i just really thought that it might be
yeah and i'm devastated and you know i
watched the whole well not the whole
like uh like the whole second half which
by the way was the longest
two hours of my life
um and i just really cannot like i don't
think i want to permanently be a sports
girly it's extremely distressing
to feel so invested and i'm in
pennsylvania right now so you can
download the draftking sportsbook and
just like bet on sports which is so
crazy so me brian and john collectively
we put like 800 on the 49ers
and like literally by the end of the
game like everyone was looking at me
like why did we listen to you and i'm
like i don't know i don't know why
anyone listened to me i just showed them
a picture of kyle use check and they
were really excited about it so i don't
know it was all so hopeful you know we
were we were having so much fun until we
weren't
yeah well i feel like with every team
they're like you just said like joe
burrow you know stood out to you i feel
like every time there's a super bowl we
like learn about some of these
heartthrobs on the teams and there's
jimmy garoppolo yeah so there's always
someone that you can really get behind
so yeah that's true that like even when
it was patrick mahomes like it we will
make
and maybe we'll find you know some some
toasters in the locker room
at the bengals and the rams
no i'm now um like really i mean i don't
want to throw my weight behind a team
and curse them again so
i do want to say like i will be rooting
for the bangles i will be even though
i'll be rooting for the bangles as well
that was where i was going
even though i have you know a sold-out
show at the wilbur theater then at a
super bowl so like i won't even be
watching so it actually doesn't even
matter
but i just feel like the rams are
extremely toxic
sean mcvay is just like
i don't know he's just not
he's not it for me in my opinion you
know in my opinion
he's not your cup of tea no
okay no when i just feel like the rams
like this is gonna be an extremely hot
take okay
i just feel like the rams are a
fraudulent
franchise i said it yeah they're they're
fraudulent is it because they're so new
yes and it's like it's just not fair
that like they're new and they
automatically have like so many fans
like they don't have to work for it
because it's like la i can't explain it
it's just extremely toxic
i feel that and also like this is so
mean but i just feel like people in l.a
will be so annoying if they win
and it's like i feel the opposite i
think peop
i'd rather see like people in cincinnati
get to like behave that way and be like
excited yeah you know and be like natty
proud as opposed to being like la proud
which is like
every day right no i
i think that people in la really need to
experience a loss collectively and
that's why we will be supporting the
bengals
but the rams lost recently right
i was trying to go back
they were in the super bowl like
in recent years yeah yeah i don't think
they were in the super bowl they were i
swear they were because um
i remember like uh stassi's husband is a
big rams fan and they all went
whenever i think of the rams i think of
beau and i think of teddy mellencamp's
husband also and i want it for them if
it was just the two of them i would be i
want it for them but overall i just
can't but the whole city is toxic
[Laughter]
i refuse to support and i think
cincinnati you know i've been reading
some stats you know underdog there's
like one player who did something very
cool for his town and
i think i love when they give back to
the community but i also think you can
find a player on every team who's done
something great for his
town well really one from the rams does
not come across my desk so
you're going to be inundated today
you're going to be inundated with ram no
seriously
i just feel like if you out yourself as
a rams fan like you're toxic i can't
explain it like go bangles all the way
like the way i never even heard of the
bengals a week ago and now i would
literally take a bullet for them
that's so like
that's the beauty of sports yeah well
for most people it's not like that
because people are so invested it's so
nice to really
not have a horse in the race and just be
able to be
such a flip-flopper because it's just so
less
high stakes i can't relate to people
whose whole like day and mood
rely on whether or not their team is
going to win which they have no
influence over
yeah i i think it's
sports if you really boil it down is an
extremely toxic community
yeah i agree but i think when you
approach it from you know like a a wide
lens like we are it can be really fun to
engage unless you're losing money which
is really upsetting yeah but you know
what i was also playing blackjack
on my phone during the game and i made
up the money that i lost
against the the regular game so i
actually netted even on draftkings
sportsbook i just have to figure out how
to withdraw my money from the app i
can't figure it out
interesting you should be able to then
from there like take your earnings and
like put them in robinhood or something
you know i'm head you are so fiscally
responsible you totally should be able
to do that or like into bitcoin that's a
great call
thanks that's a bitcoin yeah
buy some doge oh my god james
so good i didn't watch the second part
speaking of tv recap um i watched salt
lake city last night but i didn't get
the chance to watch euphoria because i
fell asleep on the couch right after the
uh 49ers game ended so i'm not sure when
i'll watch it but i won't be recapping
that today but i have so much like so
much to say about salt lake city that i
feel as though salt lake city deserves
its entire
moment in the tv recap okay i mean i
know a lot of people like apparently
euphoria was crazy last night so people
are going to be disappointed but
i don't think you were in like i know
and it's going to be really hard for me
i don't think you were in the head space
last night to take it on
no i literally like was a deeply unwell
human being after going to brunch last
night well brunch yesterday and then i
got home last night and then like the
49ers came so i just like had to drink
keep drinking um but it's gonna be
really hard for me to avoid spoilers
until i'm able to watch euphoria but
brian doesn't watch it so i'm not gonna
like force him to watch it you know oh
yeah i do know also just one more thing
how did you make out at the parks casino
casino
you know what i did relatively well i
think i like maybe lost overall a
hundred dollars like i was just really
playing for fun i was so happy like
after the show i felt very like
accomplished and all my friends were
around so i wasn't really focused on
like you know paying my rent at the
casino i just
yeah i was just playing for fun like a
couple couple hands nothing crazy no and
also like losing a hundred dollars
that's like the price of an evening of a
fun evening with friends you get free
drinks you probably would have spent
more if you guys spent all that time in
a bar so on cocktails it all eats out
okay yeah i know i felt really good
about that that's your sports news are
you going to be betting on the super
bowl
i don't know i just like can't really be
that invested because i'm working that
day and i just like my brain will be
very focused on my show so probably not
like this is probably the peak of my
interest in sports and we'll try again
next year
i feel that i feel that and
i just hope you know everyone who's
excited about it gets what they're
looking for i don't know what else to
say
about this
about these things yeah just go bangles
okay our next story is so exciting like
breaking news from this morning rihanna
is pregnant she and asap rocky are
expecting their first baby
rihanna took to the streets of new york
city the couple was photographed over
the weekend where she debuted her baby
bump while wearing a long pink jacket
her oversized outerwear was unbuttoned
at the bottom to reveal her growing bump
adorned in a gold cross with colorful
colorful jewels the pictures are so
sickening rihanna looks so stunning and
this is just like such unexpected happy
beautiful news
it's so unexpected and first of all this
is so rihanna like some people have you
know maternity shoots they have like
these big announcements they post on
instagram no she just walks around with
bella hanging out and wants everyone to
know that she's pregnant like it's it's
iconic in so many different ways also
what does this mean for us fenty baby
like there's just a lot on the horizon
now that we know she's pregnant like the
world will never and can never be the
same
yeah no
it's so exciting for
and also another person to be like
excited even though we have just a
little bit of crossover now it's like
it's the club just keeps getting better
but i feel like anytime
you it's not always a good time to be
pregnant and you can always find people
who are um doing great stuff for their
town who are pregnant
how
how many um months do you think she is
based on that belly
four or five
yeah i i don't know i would say but it's
so crazy everyone carries so differently
especially for her first pregnancy
sometimes it can take a really long time
to see
the bump so it's hard to speculate
and i don't think yeah i'm so happy for
her
i'm so happy for her they look so happy
these pictures are iconic i i can just
like
already see them like in 10 years i was
looking back on these pictures being
like that's the coolest
couple ever and an amazing announcement
yeah it's a moment and i just wasn't
expecting a moment when i woke up this
morning
no not at all and that's what i love
about rihanna like she really makes
decisions for herself based on like what
will make her the most happy not like
you know i think a lot of when you're a
woman in the industry like you plan like
your career and your family like you try
and time it all right but rihanna's just
out here like doing whatever the [ __ ]
she wants and we just love to see a
woman succeed
and i cannot wait you i mean there has
to be fenty baby right
i don't know i mean it rolls off the
tongue
so
it's such a good name it is a good name
okay well i'm so happy i hope we get
like more content and stuff but even if
this is what all we ever see like it's
more it would be enough dayenu
it would be enough dayanu we're already
so blessed to have gotten this like one
random photo of her stomach i just
wasn't expecting that like and you know
how we oh my god you know how we were
talking about the other week how i
started putting on people magazine
notifications on my phone even though
like because i'm such an internet sleuth
like everything they notified me on i
found out two hours ago right
i did find out not only that rihanna was
pregnant this morning
from my people news notification also
another story that we have about hoda i
did find out also from my people
magazine so it does come in handy
sometimes oh interesting that's why you
were trying to influence the fast five
today yes because i didn't know if you
had seen the stories i actually i did
one last i had five and then i did one
last sweep quickly and i saw rihanna and
then i saw that you wanted to talk about
uh hoda as well which i guess would be a
great segue into our next story just
gonna move some things around sure and i
just wanted to give you know a shout out
to people magazine apple notifications
because i did kind of you know disgrace
them a couple weeks ago yeah but still
don't get carried away with some
breaking news recipes from the pioneer
woman
[Laughter]
agreed
but some more breaking news that bro
claudia's heart today hoda kotb and joel
shiffman break up after eight years
together hoda and joel who got engaged
in 2019 and share two daughters are
going their separate ways she announced
today on the today show
she said joel and i i found this very
shocking joel and i have had a lot of
prayerful and meaningful conversations
over the holidays and we decided that
we're better as friends and parents than
we are as an engaged couple so we
decided we are going to start this new
year on our new path as loving parents
to our adorably delightful children and
as friends it's not like something
happened they say sometimes
relationships are meant to be there for
a reason a season or a lifetime this was
for a season
i feel i mean
very well said i agree like sometimes
that not everything needs to be drama
like not something had to have happened
like sometimes just two people drifted
apart i just was extremely shocked by
this and i think that a lot of people
will feel very connected to the story
because hoda is like this
this like beacon for a lot of women i
think i think like she found love really
late in life and she
like put her career first for so long
and i think that she was kind of the
epitome of like a woman having it all
you know like the successful career the
family the kids and like she did it and
she was really like an inspiration she
is an inspiration to so many and i just
thought like i thought that was the end
of her story you know like i didn't know
that there was gonna be a sequel that
you know she and joel broke up and now
hoda's back on the scene a sequel that
may or may not be made into a movie
correct yeah no this is surprising but
it's also like nice when people
split up knowing they're doing the right
thing and the best thing for themselves
and it's like actually you know she's
elevating to more happiness once she
gets through you know the changes in the
and the
sadness of the end of a relationship
it's like if this is best for hoda then
hoda's on a journey to further happiness
you know yeah and that's all we want in
this world like further happiness for
hoda it's just
it's a tough pill to swallow for the
hote stands honestly but don't the hoda
sans just want what's i guess it's hard
i i mean you could say they do they want
what's best for hoda i agree when all of
my ships went down last year and like if
you said to me but this is what's best
for lala like that's it still hurt it's
best for kim it's still hurt of course
so it's best for hoda but it still hurts
of course
and i was just really surprised by this
i don't know why it's not like i thought
about and it's not even like i had a
ship out for hoda and
and joel i just
i don't know i just thought like that
was it for her you know like it was a
happy ending yeah and some things are
just like so stable that you don't think
about them and then it really can like
rock your foundation when too many of
those like stable elements load-bearing
couples
go down
crumble i completely agree
so
i would look forward to seeing who you
know hoda dates next
and you know that's the tough thing
about being like uh like a
morning show queen that like millions of
people just like love to watch because
you do have to like go on tv and talk
about like really painful like personal
things the moment they happen
um so i think what she said was really
beautiful but that like probably is like
the worst part of the job honestly like
can't you just break up in peace yeah
but it's they broke up over the holidays
so she's had a month of peace to like
figure out and it's not like she's raw
and having to share this like she it
seemed you know she's a month into the
process and she's ready to share so i
think you know it's nice that none of
this leaked or anything and she was able
to let everyone else know on her own
terms that's actually a really good
point but it's also probably really hard
to date when you're a morning show host
because you know like in morning glory
you go to dinner at five o'clock and you
have to wake up at like 3 a.m and that's
just really not conducive for the dating
scene
but that's what we learned from that
amazing life-changing film is that it's
best to kind of date someone in your
industry like maybe hoda can like get it
get into it with a producer or something
you know someone who shares your
timeline someone who won't think it's
weird to go to dinner at five o'clock
and be in bed by 7 30. yeah i think she
needs to date a fellow morning show
person she needs a date in her circle
yeah
well are you ready for our next story
if it's a next story that's brought to
you by solo stove there's nothing quite
like the feeling of gathering around a
warm fire on a cold evening and a
smokeless fire pit from solo stove makes
your outdoor moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and actually enjoy the fire
and right now you can get a great deal
on a solo stove fire pit from your gals
at the morning toast so it's a great way
to update your backyard if you don't
have like a you know the the space or
the budget for like a full-blown fire
pit which is actually just like not even
a great way to make a fire sometimes the
solo stove is amazing it's portable it's
stainless steel it makes a perfect fire
there's so little smoke it's just the
best way to really elevate your backyard
on a budget and it's really the most
effective way to have like a gorgeous
campfire moment with all your friends
s'mores
sing along everything
it's made with premium grade 304
stainless steel and a 360 airflow system
that maximizes efficiency while
minimizing smoke it's super easy to
light with just a few bits of starter
and it's perfectly portable you can take
the solo stove with you on camping trips
and more it's perfect for your backyard
just throw it in the car too shop now
and get up to 30 off fire pits all month
long and use promo code toast at
checkout to get an extra 10 off plus a
lifetime warranty and free 30-day
returns but that's when you go to
solostove.com and use code toast to get
the 10 off promo code toast
solostove.com
the best thing ever we've had so many
good times with the solo stove s'mores
campfires and less smoke getting into
your eyes making you cry
and you don't take a shower and wash
your hair because your hair doesn't
smell like smoke anymore yep
next story some legal news erica jane
has been dismissed from the embezzlement
and fraud lawsuit against tom gerardi so
this weekend was like really crazy in
the real house eyes of beverly hills
world a lot's going on this is the
biggest news the star has been dismissed
from the embezzlement and fraud lawsuit
against her estranged husband quote
pursuant to stipulation plaintiff's
claims against defendants ej global llc
and erica gerardi are dismissed without
prejudice and without costs the legal
documents read the ruling came one day
after both parties agreed dismissal is
appropriate according to a separate
filing also obtained by page six
now
people are reporting that this case has
been dismissed it's just being moved to
california so it's like not actually
a legal win but in these articles it
doesn't say that
so i'm confused okay i don't know when
everyone with like a fan account on
instagram became like a legal expert yes
so i guess yes technically this could be
dismissed just so they could redo it in
a new state that i guess that's possible
but for right now i'm just believing
what's in the news and erica must be
overjoyed like not only is this a huge
burden off of her financially
emotionally
but also it's like a big [ __ ] you to
like everyone who all the doubters
non-believers
yeah it really isn't for it to happen
while they're filming they're on a cash
trip in aspen i think there's been drama
um there's been like unfollowings
between sutton erica garcelle sutton
re-followed erica garcelle does not
follow erica even though they're
literally in aspen right now on a trip
like sharing a plane and i think that
there's a lot behind yeah plus now this
is happening plus like witnesses saw
them at you know one of their dinners or
events like and there was a lot of
drama happening so it was like a big
filming weekend for them and with this
news it's going to be even crazier but
um to me from what i was reading i'm
happy for erica what i was trying to
understand is like that this is not the
end but these headlines like make it
seem like it's over
so i'm really confused i mean i guess
we'll have to wait and see and we'll see
what erica's explanation for it is on
housewives but
there's no way to know until there's
another like case filed against her but
for right now there's not right right
exactly so we'll be so this is a win
this yeah this is a win and i think in
the last year it's been there's not been
a lot of those for erica so i'm sure she
is
beyond relieved
beyond and looks like a big [ __ ] you to
like
sutton and just everyone who was like
erica's gonna be in jail i mean i don't
i honestly haven't really i don't know
how i felt about this for a long time i
felt very conflicted
because at first i was like hell bent on
honestly her being fired she is
responsible
but then the more i heard her talk about
it and more things that came out i was
like well
it's possible she didn't know
and now what is it like a year and a
half two years later
i'm pretty sure homegirl didn't know
i don't know
i i i probably i think she didn't know
because i don't i just don't think that
she did and i think there was a lot of
other things in her marriage that she
didn't know either but the way that i
ended with how i felt was like i thought
erica was one person who was just like
this whip smart like nothing gets by her
sharp as a tack
kind of person and
if it's true that she didn't know that
all of these things were going on like
in her home with her husband and he was
really this like awful awful person then
she's not that first person that i
thought that she was and and my
admiration is well that's a totally fair
my admiration is just not where it was
pre all of this but like if she innocent
and didn't know that doesn't make her an
accomplice though right right like stay
on the show that's totally fine um but
it's just like changed how i saw her
no that's a good analysis of the
situation
okay
so anyways this is just like great for
beverly hills i can't believe she's like
after last season you just wouldn't have
thought that there was any coming out of
this for her but she's a fighter as she
said that she was
the strongest substance isn't diamonds
it's her
there was rumors she was gonna be on
celebrity big brother did she get cast i
know teddy mellencamp did but i think
that
erica did not
i didn't hear that rumor i just saw a
picture of the cast recently people are
quaking because lamar odom and
shanna mochler shanna moekler yeah both
on and they're both kardashian x's so
who knows they're both kardashian
associates yeah who knows i can't wait
i mean yeah it will be so funny keep us
posted if anything goes down because you
know we won't be watching
no yeah i don't watch but it is an
interesting concept for a show
oh for sure especially if you like the
original show but it's it's so much
bandwidth in time like it's every single
night
the
the cameras that you have to watch
online it's just like a full-time job
being a big brother fan in my opinion
yeah it's like love island
which you loved yes i'd love i did love
love island i can't wait for it to come
back we didn't even talk about that cash
and cinco broke up ted lasso
oh
okay well i was talking about how they
had like a they had a love island spoof
show on ted lasso which i loved yeah no
that was cute but cash and cinco broke
up
that was a really
very difficult pill to swallow like
because now shannon and josh are
together and kyra and will right i
haven't heard anything about karen well
are they together i don't keep up with
anyone
[Music]
i don't know i check in on the couples
like every couple of weeks because i
follow shannon and josh and they're so
otp that like it kills me and they
should have won um
but cash and cinco was really like
really heartbreaking that was a tough
pill to swallow like i was really upset
kira's instagram looks like a single
girl's instagram
there's no sign of blue no
well we know that olivia and cory broke
up even though they were never together
so i think it's
the whole country the nation
they literally took the nation for a
ride but now
fraudulently
i don't feel like any sort of you know
rdh about them because we could sniff it
out from the beginning but if you fell
for that
you know what if you fell for that
you deserved to be sh to be
fooled because you're easily fooled yeah
yeah
but
sad about cash and cinco but they did
they that it's been what six seven
months since the show air
that's a good real shot at love
you know that's not just i do think that
that's not waiting the requisite time
before it's acceptable to break up
here i mean agreed
corey yeah i know what you mean yeah i
just do think that um
like it was a great relationship i would
like to think that it was a great
relationship for both of them and they
look back on it fondly and i hope nobody
cheated on one another it was just like
a difference
of lifestyle or wherever you know where
residents like i just hope it's all
ended in an amicable way
yes i feel like it it probably did
i don't know okay you never know what
you never know devastating devastating
okay well are you ready for our fifth
and final story
yes
okay it's some very sad news miss usa
2019 chesley crist dies at age 30. miss
usa 2019 chesley has died her family has
confirmed to people she was 30 years old
authorities say she died sunday after
jumping from a 60-story building at 350
west 42nd street in new york city around
7 15 a.m local time she reportedly lived
on the ninth floor of the building and
was last seen on the 29th floor terrace
um
her family put out a statement saying in
devastation and great sorrow we share
the passing of our beloved chesley her
great light was one that inspired others
around the world with her beauty and
strength she cared she loved she laughed
and she shined
this story just broke my heart this is
so terrible
so terrible
terrible like
what
oh my god i have no words honestly
no and like we were just talking about
this
like last week when we were talking
about regina king's um
son
literally
so
upsetting
the mental health crisis
in this country it's just it's horrible
and it's
like you look at a girl like that with
her whole life ahead of her who's so
accomplished like you just want to cry
when you hear the story yeah you really
do everyone like is writing obviously
the swedish tributes about her but it
just seems like she was one of those
people who like lit up a room brought so
much joy to so many people and
to know that she was struggling
to this point it's just it's
heartbreaking
it's so sad it's horrible
yeah so i just think you know we should
all like when we hear these stories like
learn from it in a sense and like check
in on our friends and family because
like look you look at her you see her
instagram she's this beautiful girl so
accomplished you would never think in a
million years that something like this
would happen yeah that's what life is
like everyone puts on a show and inside
like everyone is struggling in different
ways so just i i think the takeaway here
is like just be nice to everyone because
you really never know what anyone's
going through
and just check in on your friends
because you really never know yeah i
would agree
so sad to end the stories on on a sad
note but we'll turn it around with the
real housewives of salt lake city recap
yes i did watch the real housewives of
salt lake city and i watched meredith on
watch weapons live with bridget everett
the queen of literally entertainment
invented comedy the tv recap is brought
to you by omaze if you've ever dreamed
of having the chance to win awesome
prizes
like winning a tesla a karaoke night
with charlize theron going to space with
virgin galactic then you have to check
out omaze the new way to give back to
charity and have fun while doing it
here's how it works you enter for the
chance to win something amazing and at
the same time you can donate to support
great causes it's fun and easy
it's a great way for non-profits to
raise money and for you to win big
prizes like a multi-million dollar home
in lake tahoe here's how it works go to
omaze.com toast omaze.com
toast and select the lake tahoe dream
house the deadline to enter is april
14th so hurry on your chance if you miss
the deadline don't worry they have tons
of other prizes and experiences that you
can choose from and through your
donations omaze has raised more than 150
million dollars to support over 350
nonprofits around the world everyone
deserves a chance to live their dreams
and with omaze's extraordinary prizes
those dreams are within reach for
everyone hurry and enter today for your
chance to win the lake tahoe dream house
or any other life-changing prizes and
experiences at omaze.com toast plus
receive 20 extra entries when you use
code toast 20. that's t-o-a-s-t
at omaze
omaze.com toast um no purchase necessary
to enter or win visit omaze.com for
official rules
so the real housewives of salt lake city
was yet again another infuriating
episode but it did end with the hot mic
of all hot mics i was shook by what was
coming out of lisa barlow's mouth
because they teased she's [ __ ] half of
new york but they didn't tease the rest
of it her family that is posing her
husband who gets a new job every five
minutes
it was wild and you know i tuned in to
watch what happens live because i wanted
to hear meredith's take on it and
meredith meredith should literally like
work in dc she is so
like political in the sense like she's
very well media trained she had the
perfect answer she didn't stutter they
asked her about jenny when she had the
perfect answer like she doesn't miss and
so when when she was asked about the hot
mic
she said well there is truth in what she
said yes my husband does change jobs
quite frequently he's an executive of
turn around so he's doing his job well
if he's moving to new jobs every couple
of months so i thought that was a great
answer she said she didn't know what
that what lisa meant when she said my
family poses
but she also said that her and seth have
been very open with one another they
haven't seen other people for two years
but you know when they were separated
they did see other people and her and
seth have spoken about it so she hasn't
[ __ ] half of new york because it was
only a couple years where they were
seeing other people but
yeah she's [ __ ] other people she said
i've never [ __ ] more than 10 people in
my life so i couldn't even [ __ ] half of
new york
right i mean
of course she didn't [ __ ] half of new
york she also accused lisa of like
projecting as if these are things about
lisa the family poses thing i think
she's calling her family posers perhaps
maybe
i don't think it was out like actually
doing poses i don't know i'm sure there
will be clarification but andy clarified
remember how we did that story because
andy said on radio andy something
happens between two ladies that we've
never seen um
salt lake city reunion this is it which
is a little bit of like a disappointment
but the fact that the night before the
reunion meredith saw this and then
is reacting to it the next day i think
it's a lot
and it's a lot more powerful than if
like it aired they obviously have phone
conversations about it they rehash it at
the reunion like i think it's very very
raw for meredith and it's always nice to
you know
get
put a button on some of the questions
like okay what was he talking about and
it's not this like big jen meredith
thing it's this which is actually
it was pretty crazy and the footage
usually they overhyped stuff this was
under hyped agreed
yeah agreed and the dinner in and of
itself was just so chaotic like mary and
jenny going after each other like was so
funny because mary's just like
she's atrocious but she does have some
like moments that are so iconic like so
you don't want to be friends with jenny
no like just very plain why would they
want to be friends like and mary's right
like none of these women are friends
like if it weren't for the show they all
act like they owe each other their lives
and they should all have each other's
backs most of them met two years ago
like let's not be stupid like so whitney
acting like her and mary her and mary
would never be friends in the real world
like they couldn't be more different
yeah all of these women i mean aside
from the ones who came in as friends
like would not be friends that's the
thing with like lisa and whitney like
and why they are really like oil and
water because they're just like two
different girls but you know the more
that the rest of the group is divided
the more that they have come together
because like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend i think and it's just it's like
it's so like looking at like a board of
this season and who's like aligned to
who who's having who's back like is so
[ __ ] confusing like the way that
these fights just kept turning in
different directions and like everyone
when the it was like hot potato and when
like the drama came to them they're like
this isn't my drama like but everybody's
like no and
involved in the drama and also
irrelevant to it
and the way there's so much drama and so
much animosity but not one conversation
last night was had about gen shaw
allegedly defrauding vulnerable and old
people is beyond my comprehension like
the fact that jenny jenny is so
such a [ __ ] i'm sorry like the way that
she sits there and is like really
gaslighting everyone into thinking that
meredith's uh father's memorial was a
lie like you're kidding right like for
you're kidding like that is so stupid
whitney heather jenny
so moronic like and none of them even
want to look twice over at jen shawn be
like hey you lie all the time and you
were just arrested should we talk about
that ever or no let's keep making up
things that meredith
turned you into the fbi and that she
lied about her [ __ ] dad's memorial
it's so stupid no and like jen cha says
things with such conviction and it's
like
if you just turn it around on her
it's like it's so glaring and hip
hypocritical like even okay they're
accusing meredith about lying about her
dad's funeral but like jen lied about
her husband having internal bleeding in
order to get off the bus like what about
that and she never explained why she
lied about that right and so she says
like if so and so if meredith can lie
about this what else is she lying about
jen like you've lied about your whole
[ __ ] life what else are you lying
about it's just like it's like the enemy
of like people in glass houses shouldn't
throw stones but it's like so i'm just
like where and she says most of it in
her interview so like no one can really
call her out but like even if she said
at the table like still no one would
call her out also i saw a tweet last
night that was like she gave all the
women diamond necklaces which is like so
crazy on a number of levels while she
also like drained her mother's
retirement fund in order to pay her
uh legal bills like why not just return
those necklaces that you had just bought
and that the women didn't even know
existed
i'm extremely grateful to meredith for
being the only normal one to point out
like
she has like a two million dollar legal
bill they're talking about moving into a
different house her mother who's a
teacher who saved up her whole life is
draining her retirement fund to defend
her daughter in a legal battle against
the fbi and no one's curious why she's
the only housewife who brought glam
she paid for dinner and gave everyone
diamond necklaces these women are morons
i'm sorry they are dropping the ball
so hard they're fighting between
themselves about
nothing
nothing and nobody has questioned jensha
since the moment she got arrested this
is the worst group of housewives i've
ever
like literal amateur hour it's beyond my
comprehension how bad whitney and
heather are two of the worst housewives
i literally every time they speak i'm
like wrong dumb thing to say wrong
everything is wrong everything they
[ __ ] say is wrong it's infuriating
yeah i
retweet i completely agree it's like
staring right in front of them and that
instead they're like looking for other
leads what day was meredith's dad's
funeral even though like a perfectly
logical explanation it's so stupid i
can't a perfectly logical explanation
there are so many but one could be on
monday was the memorial tuesday before
the women got there she was still with
her family so when lisa is like i'm
sorry to call you with your family she's
like it's just so stupid they really
think they have a smoking gun when there
is a gun on fire in front of them and
they're like
where who refusing to look to look at it
it's so crazy
reunion that lisa barlow lost her [ __ ]
like over
what we saw last night is crazy like the
fact that meredith that's what andy said
on watch weapons live
and meredith said that apparently it had
stemmed from
lisa had heard meredith called her house
ugly even if it was that but like
lisa started not to be like she started
it like lisa started this whole trend of
i'm not picking friends over friends and
i can be friends with meredith and i can
be friends with jen even though the two
of you [ __ ] hate each other and even
though one of you has been my friend for
10 years and has like long before this
show
i'm still gonna you know be just as get
closer than ever with someone who really
really hurt you so now
the fact that meredith is being like
okay we can do that we can have you know
friends and just try not to be involved
and and that's lisa's reaction it's she
these women just can't see themselves
and i actually do like lisa and i'm sure
that's something that's exactly what
bridget everett said on watch rappin's
live by the way she's like literally
lisa started this whole thing
oh amazing i actually watch i watch most
of watch what happens live but i must
have uh missed that bridget is
everything she really is she was totally
on the right side of his story like i
just love her you love to see it no
meredith i agree with you she is such a
politician and so diplomatic and just
never she really and i think that's also
what makes her a frustrating housewife
it's so crazy like you ever look at the
tweets after salt lake city to see like
what the temperature is no i can't even
though i know that we are in the
minority
not take us out of it every
there's no like clear majority from what
i've seen on twitter even though i think
oftentimes like the tweets especially
the ones that like are really popular
don't represent have a lot of people
feel but like there are some people who
are like meredith mark stan there are
other people who are like like she's the
worst there are people who are like mary
cosby can do no wrong there are other
people and it's like there's no
clear
goat of the show narrative yeah you know
it's so it's so odd people are like
whitney's iconic like what
what no whitney's literally the
definition of not iconic at all like
she's literally the worst she's her and
heather like they just they got so
confident after everyone loved them
season one that they turned into
villains oh and there's also people who
are like lisa is like the the she know
queen like me like everything is just
honestly i could
i could see someone standing lisa i
could see someone standing meredith i
don't see how anyone in their right mind
anyone with a working brain cell could
be on whitney and had their side
honestly they are such bullies people
and they're so delusional there are
people who think like whitney and
heather are like the queens of this show
keeping it going i don't know people who
think it's jen there are people think
it's really like it's so crazy i've
never seen a responsibility like that
that's all over the place
nobody thinks it's jenny she like really
every time she speaks think she's doing
something and i just like want to die
inside it's like girl
stop like for i'll stop this is like not
about you but like i appreciate what
you're trying to do here but like
seriously just shut up
yeah no and the conversation at the spa
when she was like sharing and trying to
open up and i think once like she saw
that mary wasn't gonna do the same and
that is how you okay so they got off on
the wrong foot mary apologized today's a
new day like we're with meredith who is
like a mutual good friend of ours and
like maybe we'll just like open up and
and get a little closer that is like how
friendships progress
but once mary was like no i'm not
talking about this i don't know you
message received move on like move on
now mary has just made it extremely
clear she's not interested in one iota
of a friendship with jenny so jenny
needs to seriously move on it's not
happening and also
the fact that jenny only brought it up
at the dinner table once mary had gotten
up it's just like weak
weak
weak spineless behavior like bring it up
when mary's sitting there or don't bring
it up at all because you know it was it
was could have been a done moot point
but like oh my god
when heather and started coming for mary
and mary was like because you don't have
a husband which was like such a mean
thing to say but then mary jo you wanna
know what right into who
husband slander i'm sorry
okay i have something to say okay i
actually don't think it was that mean of
a thing to say because in the preview
i'm like oh my that's really rude why
are you just randomly bringing up but
jenny is throwing in mary's face jenny
and heather are like you know dewey was
one of the husbands who paid for this so
like you know you're on a trip that was
technically purchased by okay
heather your husband didn't pay for
anything because you don't have a
husband it it sounded mean but they were
like throwing the money thing in mary's
face and mary threw it right back who
the [ __ ] are you to say that heather
your husband didn't pay for anything
sorry i didn't see it i thought it was
fair i thought she was saying it like
because i guess it's like unclear first
of all did the husbands even pay for
this trip or was it bravo like
yes
who they're they're claiming the
husband's paid for it okay would that
include robert senior
unclear
so if it's not robert singer and if the
husband's really paid for it and robert
singer didn't and everybody knew that
then yes heather's saying her husband
sent her on this trip and then mary
might have taken that as a slight i see
that but when i watched it last night
that's not how i took it i thought
heather was being like uh the husband
sent us here to you know like repro shma
and get along and make everything better
and mary just like
sort of threw that in her face and was
like you don't have a husband and just
walked right into step grandfather
territory
heather literally said like dewey paid
for it like she brought up the money and
i'm sorry i thought mary was 100
justified in that nasty comment for real
have you also seen these rumors that
mary is filming this next season
new rumors
rumors of fresh that she's like filming
personal scenes that's why they went to
look for her at the church but then last
night i don't watch what happens live
meredith said mary's no longer on the
show so i'm confused
yeah no i don't think those rumors are
true that would make literally no sense
it would make no sense and i do think it
would set a horrible precedent because
then women could skip reunions i think
having that like be like i don't care
who you are i don't care how much you
bring to the show agree if you don't
come to the reunion and answer show up
for what you've done then you're out and
i
think even though like the show would
benefit from having mary on it
i think it would be a great horrible
precedent so i'm just we'll see agreed
agreed
okay because then women will do it all
the time honestly
i guess it's just right it grinds my
gears to see such a logic
being displayed
on my television like i don't know how
much more i can take i hope and i
actually i i i do not envy andy's job at
the reunion of trying to sift through
this garbage
because it's like it's a maze that's
just there's no clear path of of what
even are the root issues
you don't have my back i hope andy has
his head on straight i hope andy has his
head on straight like i just i pray he
doesn't drop the ball because these
women have fumbled so atrociously and
wasted what could have been an amazing
season and i know a lot of people still
like the season and people are always
telling us you guys are in the minority
okay that might be true but i've been
watching housewives for literally 15
years i know what this season could have
been and i know what it is and i know
it's not as good as it should have been
yeah and i just i like to watch people
making sense making good points and like
being true being logical that's not what
i'm getting so it's disappointing no
um but other than that
that's our show
that is our show i'm glad we got that
off our chest but it's just
it makes me feel like i'm losing my mind
even recapping salt lake city sometimes
because i'm like what is going on
truly totally i don't know um
tomorrow what's on tonight nothing
nothing for us but you'll watch euphoria
and um maybe i'll get back into poldark
i'll figure it out i think i think i
need a longer break from ross paul dark
and his antics
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast and we're podcasts can be
found spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast box all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find some morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys all have
an amazing day and we will see you
tomorrow bye bye